another great edition of the Monday
Morning Quarterback that you must check
out at the mmq be calm Peter back on the
show how are you Peter rich I wish they
were still the disaster I was
unfortunately they're really really good
they good they are good so I kind of
think it's gonna be a Houston Cleveland
ALCS but maybe our two teams can do some
about it well no I hear you
and III agree with you in Houston sports
I mean with obviously Chris Paul joining
Rockets and now I mean I mentioned
bonafide stars in the league
deshaun Watson appears to be all that
and the proverbial biscuit Peter I mean
what did you think of his performance
over the last several weeks and his
viability to take a team in the playoffs
this year what do you think well I think
what big things about this John Watson
is that you know and I've said this ever
since the Scouting Combine I pride
myself really on I don't want to say
pride myself but I I fully admit that I
watch very little college football the
only college football I've watched this
year or the steak Juan Barkley highlight
yeah and this just in he might make it
so so so I don't know very much about
college they know is that there's one
human being on planet Earth
who is twice thrown for 400 yards
against a Nick Saban coach defense and
that's deshaun Watson and from the time
I got to the Scouting Combine for the
time of the NFL Draft all I ever heard
was oh well I don't know if this guy's
an NFL quarterback I mean come on
what what what what is what is he then I
I don't I I don't know what the big
difference is I do know that that spread
quarterbacks and option quarterbacks and
and and you know shotgun exclusive
quarterbacks I I understand that that's
an adjustment but we have gotten this
thing into our heads that because so
many of them don't really make it or
have trouble making it that some
but he really can't make it and they
don't want to pay and people don't want
to take a risk man I watched some of his
highlights from Clemson and he was that
he was just a really really good player
and I think the one thing about him is
that and this Bill O'Brien found this
out right away rich when you get old
Brian on the show or when you get and
when you get to Charlotte said on the
show you got to ask him about the text
messages that O'Brien while they were
both on vacation late June and July text
message quizzes that O'Brien would send
to Sean Watson while both of them are on
vacation and Watson aced them all and so
this is this is not a shock I think the
people who know him well and I think
it's uh you know good things happen to
good people everybody saw what he did
last week and giving his first game
check the three women who work in the
lunchroom for the Texans and they there
they got a lot of damage in the floods
Houston and he split his game trek among
the three of them so this is a good
human being so I'm glad good things are
happening to him and he gets the NBC
spotlight coming up in six days Chiefs
and Texans and we see the Chiefs tonight
they may or may not be undefeated when
we see them on NBC next week a Peter
King of the mmq be joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show ask him the poll
question is a way to open up the the
interview in a more omnibus fashion here
brockman go for it okay Peter we have
some very good teams at 2 & 2 which one
of these is most likely to miss the
playoffs Cowboys Patriots Raiders
Seahawks what do you think Peter I would
say Raiders because of the competition
for the playoff spots in the AFC because
and because I don't know what the fate
of Derek Carr is what if he misses five
weeks and you got to play EJ Manuel what
he may miss no one week I don't know and
I also think that you know that offense
which pay I covered him against the Jets
and the Jets are supposed to have a good
Benson and the and the Raiders just
absolutely shredded them and then the
last two weeks
they haven't been good Marshawn Lynch
two weeks in a row absolute total
non-factor so I you know I don't know
what to think of the Raiders right now I
probably say the Raiders and I might say
Dallas second so why would you say
Dallas second I sitting there as well
because because I think as you watch
them playing you look at their schedule
which is a tough schedule I think as you
watch them play and you watch how good
Philadelphia has looked so far and how
surprisingly good Washington is look
they may not win their division rich by
the end of the night you know Washington
and Philadelphia which were supposed to
be at the bottom of that vision could be
six and two and Dallas and the Giants
who were supposed to be at the top of
the division could be two and six Oh
will be two in six so I I kind of look
at that division and say as usual down
is up yeah I mean they've got the
Packers at home than they were at the
49ers at the Redskins and then home for
the Chiefs those are the next four for
the Dallas Cowboys Peter King here on on
the Rich Eisen show and then you look at
a week five Peter there's only one game
on the docket where both teams are above
500 that's the three-in-one Panthers at
the three-in-one lions there's just a
ton of teams to like the three and one
Eagles and even in the case folks with
the three-in-one Rams although I firmly
believe they're for real is this as a
wide-open can't really even at the
quarter post point figure out who teams
are type of season right now rich I
honestly you think it usually is this
way and you know I looked at the
schedule this morning there's four or
five games that I absolutely positively
love I don't care what their records are
I mean I love for dramas sake New
England it I mean I and I don't know the
answer to this but when's the last time
the Patriots were under 500 in October I
mean I really don't know but it's
probably been since the Pleistocene era
and it's just you know that would be
fairly incredible so the Patriots are
kind of an unknown and look at all the
explosive offensive teams right now
the Rams I mean this is the weirdest I
think the weirdest thing if you told
anybody that after a quarter of the
season the Rams would be the
highest-scoring team and a patriot could
be the worst defensive team you know
that if you'd have better odds of that
happening are you had better odds of
winning powerball then of that happening
nobody would have believed you and so to
me I think we see a lot of that every
year but I thought it was really really
interesting this weekend that Carolina
went on the road and beat New England
that Buffalo went on the road and beat
Atlanta that the Rams went on the road
and beat Dallas and we're getting to the
point now where you know I talked to
Sean McVeigh last night I think one of
the things he feels like is this is the
time of year where you really start
getting to know Pink's you know where
okay a lot of things have shaken out you
know you you you know what teams to be
worried about you know what teams are
are out of it you know but but you you
kind of know after a quarter of the
season what you're looking at and and
that's why to me rich I totally agree
with you on the Rams you know Rams are
really really interesting number one and
number two everybody think to them is
the 2016 Rams and oh my god but look at
this their two most important offensive
linemen came in the offseason John
Sullivan at center and Andrew Whitworth
at left tackle their three most
important wide receivers came in the off
season in Cup Watkins and Robert woods
and the other thing that has happened
obviously the quarterback is being
coached much differently than he was
last year but you know they have made
Todd Gurley from you know they've turned
him from Eddie George into Marshall
Faulk they really have when you think
about it he no longer is just a blaster
in the middle of the line he's the guy
who right now at least in my opinion is
guy who Jared Shawn McVeigh wants to
turn into a guy who's the same kind of
threat this Marshall Faulk and he's
doing it man
and Girly's about to join me here on the
show before I let you go Peter what why
did the Bears make the move to Mitchell
Chu Brisky best you can tell it had to
be rich it had to be and I have not
talked to John Fox to ask him but it had
to be that the coaches think that true
Biscay is ready because I firmly believe
that they weren't gonna make this move
as a negative for Glennon okay even if
Glennon wasn't playing that well if they
didn't think sure Biscay was ready they
would not have done this now they get a
long week you know that to help him
prepare my gut feeling is they probably
told him over the weekend so that he
could start to get mentally prepared and
so now you look at it and you just say
here's here's a franchise that is
getting ready as much as they don't want
to say it is getting ready this is a
move for the future this is a move for
opening day 2018 and they have to feel
like that your Biscay is ready or
there's no way they would have made this
move Peter love chatting with you thanks
for calling in the mm QB dot-com and
Monday Morning Quarterback as always
must read thanks Peter Thank You Richie
you bet asked at si underscore Peter
King the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country
and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches